bon alors on relâche progressivement au
québec et en ontario progressivement
mais quand même relativement lentement
mais en même temps ottawa dit ben c'est
pas tout à fait le temps de relâcher les
variants pourrait se répandre la vitesse
grand v
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire qu'est
ce que vous en pensez en fait ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que les variants sont
plus contagieux que la souche originale
chez les adultes mais également chez les
enfants donc si comme si on avait un feu
si vous voulez des braises dans un feu
qui reste incandescente et qui au
moindre coup de vent pourraient
réapparaître un mois le moins coup de
vent pourrait ranimer le feu et brûlé
toute la forêt sèche peut dire donc dans
ce contexte il faut faire très attention
et respecter scrupuleusement les mesures
les gestes barrières les mesures
sanitaires pour éviter de se retrouver
avec ce feu de broussailles et une
hausse des cas en quelques jours ou
quelques semaines qui pourrait monter à
4 5 me est ce que vous direz donc il ne
faut pas rouvrir progressivement
présentement comme on est en train de le
faire tranquillement même si on parle
quand même d'attendre après la semaine
de relâche pour la suite des choses est
ce qu'on devrait mettre un cran d'arrêt
maintenant mais en fait il faut faire
attention oui parce que tant qu'on n'a
pas une bonne partie la personne la
population qui est vaccinés on a
toujours ce risque que les variants se
propage et en fait j'attends très en
plus au-delà de la semaine de relâche
c'est à dire j'attends des deux semaines
après la semaine de relâche pour voir
l'impact de la semaine de relâche sur la
propagation des variants et sur la
transmission communautaire
donc c'est sûr qu'il faut faire
attention et il faut attendre qu'on ait
une bonne partie de la population
vaccinée avant de pouvoir se permet de
ré offrir pourrions-nous quand même
rouvrir les salles de spectacles et
théâtre
qu'est-ce qu'on lève déjà puisqu'on le
fait déjà pour les salles de cinéma mais
là encore si on pouvait ajouter par
exemple un fils de sécurité
supplémentaires un outil supplémentaire
comme les tests rapides antigénique on
pourrait s'assurer que on le faisait en
relisant passé avant de faire entrer les
gens dans une salle de spectacle on
pourrait s'assurer que les vignerons ont
fait pas rentrer d'hyper contagieux dans
la salle dans ce contexte on aurait un
espèce d'outils un filet de sécurité
supplémentaires mais le gouvernement du
québec pour l'instant ne veut pas les
passer
car patients asymptomatiques qui
pourtant sont à l'origine d'environ 50%
des éclosions donc dans ce contexte il
faut mieux restreindre les ouvertures
vous parlez des asymptomatiques en ce
moment on présume que ils sont à l'école
également les enfants sont pour la
plupart asymptomatiques donc comment on
doit gérer cette situation si on
maintient les écoles ouverts de toute
façon on participe à une contagion en
quelques saucisses c'est sûr que les
écoles en fait sont les milieux où on a
le plus d'interactions actuellement et
c'est important de garder ouverts par
contre je salue la direction sein des
directions directeur de santé publique
qui ont fermé les écoles à la moindre
suspicion de variants puisque en fait
quand on ferme une école c'est un énorme
impact économique et social pour les
parents pour la communauté mais la
valeur des impacts négatifs en fait est
inférieur quand même à la valeur des
bénéfices associés au fait de stopper la
propagation du variant donc dans ce
contexte il faut continuer maintenant
école ouverte et si possible a ajouté
des mesures de sécurité comme les tests
rapides antigénique en californie ils le
font d'ailleurs tous les enfants passent
en californie deux fois par semaine un
test rapide avant de rentrer à l'école
kds qu'on arrive tout près d'un coup de
barre en quelque sorte parce qu'elle est
il ya 640 milles vaccin qui arrive cette
semaine au canada
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour
renverser la tendance mais en fait je me
sentirais plus disons rassuré quand on
our à vacciner nos 1 7 million personnes
de 65 ans et plus au québec où sept
millions de personnes de 65 ans et plus
au canada
et selon un calendrier vaccinal ça
devrait arriver fin avril mais il faut
quand même savoir que parmi la
population active les 20 60 ans certains
développent des symptômes graves des
symptômes un peu plus léger mais sont
forcés de rester avec les symptômes
grippaux au lit pendant plusieurs
semaines plusieurs jours ce qui fait
qu'en fait ça quand même un impact sur
l'absentéisme au travail la productivité
est particulièrement s'il ya une
éclosion dans les industries
manufacturières donc aux uns attendent
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à la fin avril est
à prévoir en fonction du nombre de
prévalence est la préférence des
variantes et de la transmission
communautaire si on peut ré ouvrir et
quand on s'intéresse comme vous le
faites là
aux équilibres aux coûts bénéfices dès
lors qu on a vacciné les 60 65 ans et
plus
est-ce qu'on a raison d'imaginer qu'on
lève l'essentiel des restrictions à
partir de ce moment là moi j'attendrais
quand même encore qu'on ait pu vacciner
60 ou 70% de la population parce que les
comme je le disais les vingt 20 60 ans
la population active va pouvoir
rattraper les variants si on lève ses
gestes les variants où la souche au
final si on laisse et si on lève les
restrictions et on risque d'avoir comme
je disais une très grande que de
transmission communautaire parlons cette
tranche la de la population et donc
beaucoup d'absentéisme et de perte de
productivité mais qui ne se transmet pas
nécessairement par une pression sur le
système de santé et les hospitalisations
sont par baysse et les décès sont en
baisse
je présume qu'on peut vivre avec ça mais
il faut faire attention quand même parce
que certains bailleurs les études
commencent à montrer du moins pour le
variés anglais par exemple certains
belle le premier ministre anglais le
disait que les variants peut être peut
faire en fait en sorte que les gens
développent des symptômes plus graves et
soit plus hospitaliser même parmi les
bases d'un 60 ans donc c'est pour ça que
je préfère appliquer le principe de
précaution est ici non d'arriver plus
tôt à une atteindre un maximum de la
vaccination
dernière question aujourd'hui marty
macquarie pas aujourd'hui mais quelques
jours professeur à la johns hopkins
school of medicine a dit que l'immunité
collective sera atteinte en avril aux
etats-unis parce que beaucoup plus de
cas que les infections rapporté il ya
des gens vaccinés on arrive pratiquement
70% d'immunité selon lui fin avril c'est
possible mais la situation des états
unis est différente celle du canada il a
raison qu'elle est très certainement
beaucoup plus de gens qui ont eu la
copie d'autant plus quand on sait qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
asymptomatiques
mais aux états unis il ya beaucoup plus
de contaminations qu'au canada est
beaucoup plus de décès par ailleurs même
si le taux d'infection énormément baissé
aux etats-unis ils ont aussi appliquée
beaucoup de gestes barrières plus de
masques par exemple que cet automne
finalement il ya beaucoup plus de
personnes qui sont vaccinées aux états
unis actuellement en fait là
il ya beaucoup plus de personnes tous
les jours son vaccine aux états unis ce
qui va continuer limitée dans une
certaine mesure la transmission
communautaire donc aux états unis
peut-être mais au canada c'est pas
certain que ce sera un qui en avril
merci beaucoup merci bien je serai clair